Welcome back to human emotion.
So one of the most important and controversial questions we've talked about last
time is what is it exactly that makes human emotion and behavior unique in the
animal kingdom?
Today we're going to take this one step further by asking this question of
whether or not our emotions are really so different or whether they're actually
quite similar to some of our closest nonhuman primate relatives.
Sort of asking the question,
is it really monkey see monkey feel?
Um,
and as we stated in the last lecture,
we can learn a lot about our own emotions by studying how unique versus how
similar they are with other species near us,
given we share a large part of our evolutionary lineage.
As you can see here with nonhuman primates,
should we ask the question of whether or not monkeys and apes can also feel
emotions just like us?
Okay.
In other words,
do they express emotions the same way we do?
So to look at some of these questions today,
our roadmap will go as follows.
We'll start by talking about emotion expression here.
We'll look at the question of whether or not a monkeys and apes actually express
emotions the same way we do,
or whether it's actually quite different.
Well then turn to questions looking at whether or not they recognize and pick up
on emotional cues from others.
And then we'll turn to this idea of complex emotions.
So what about more complex feelings like empathy or gratitude?
Is this something solely reserved for humans?
Or can monkeys also capture and experiences these more mysterious kind of higher
order feelings?
We'll conclude with our typical takeaway questions.
And then today where I'm really honored to have a special expert interview with
Doctor Lisa Parr who has developed a system for coding emotional expressions in
the chimpanzee face.
Very similar to the way we code emotional expressions and human faces.
So with that,
we'll start today with emotion expression.
As you can see here,
emotion expressions seem to be evident not only in humans,
but if you look at these photos here,
it would be hard to argue that there's no such thing as emotional expressions.
And chimpanzees,
for example.
So in humans,
we know that emotion expressions are critical for human survival.
We use our face to signal to others when we're in pain,
alert others to signals of danger or fear,
and an even more subtle and a tantalizing ways signal attraction to potential
romantic partners.
And we know a bit about how humans do this,
but we know almost nothing about how other species such as the chimpanzee,
um,
express emotions.
That is until very recently,
and as we started out by looking at these pictures,
if you look carefully out then we might all agree that these monkeys are
expressing emotions,
right?
Or,
or are they?
So here,
let's start with the observation first of where emotional expressions actually
come from.
And we'll start with the example of smiling.
So when and how do we first see emotion expressions emerge in humans?
So in humans we see expressions of joy or smiling emerge roughly within the
first 30 days of life.
And if we take kind of a cross species comparison and chimpanzees,
Lo and behold,
we see a roughly similar pattern.
We see the emergence of joy or smiling,
as you can see in this little baby chimpanzee here,
um,
emerge at roughly the same point as in humans.
Um,
we also see other striking similarities between humans and chimpanzees when it
comes to smiling.
Um,
both humans and chimpanzees smile more when they're engaging in social play
versus when they're alone.
Um,
and they also show smiles,
uh,
with their caregivers.
It's a really important part of forming that initial bond.
Um,
and social smells also serve important communicative functions.
They're ways of expressing who it is they feel comfortable with and who they
want to affiliate with.
So in many ways,
it seems that we share smiles with our closest evolutionary relatives and they
emerge roughly at the same time in development.
Okay.
So that's about smiling.
What about crying?
Yeah,
so as you can see here,
um,
the sort of expression of crying looks,
you know,
morphologically very similar.
And if we turn to crime,
we also see a similar developmental pattern.
So for example,
fussing and crying occur in the first days of life and peek around six weeks in
humans.
And we see a similar developmental pattern.
And chimpanzees crying is also an important signal between the newborn human,
uh,
and it's caregiver as well as the newborn champion.
It's caregiver to help signal distress or asking for resource such as food.
Um,
at the same time though,
humans when they cry have tears and chimpanzees have these very interesting
tearless cries.
So although there's many similarities,
there's also differences in the fact that they cry without tears.
What about things like surprise and anger?
So we see additional observations later on in the lifespan of human and
chimpanzees where we see expressions such as surprise as you can see here,
uh,
roughly similar both in chimpanzees and humans.
Okay.
If you look at anger here as well,
we seem to just by observation look really similar when we express certain
emotions.
So up to the state,
these are a lot of anecdotal observations.
How do we get more systematically into the nitty gritty of trying to really code
and understand these emotional expressions?
So here,
this is really groundbreaking work done by Lisa par and Kimbark,
um,
to striking researchers who decided to get out there and conduct this
groundbreaking research to more systematically examine,
encode emotional expressions in nonhuman primates.
And they asserted that in order to really examine whether emotional expressions
have a similar sort of a appearance and social function across Vcs,
you first need to have a comparable way to observationally code facial
expressions of emotion.
So what they did is they first turn towards the existing systematize ways of how
we code emotional expressions in humans.
And as you will recall from earlier on in our lectures,
one of the most highly regarded coding systems for sort of mapping emotional
expressions in humans is Paul Ekman,
facial action coding system or facs.
Um,
and hear what you're doing is you're identifying and coding these little bundles
of muscle contractions in the face that are called action units or a use.
So this is how we do it in humans.
This is kind of one of the gold standards of coding emotions.
How,
and as you see from earlier on,
we can code.
I'm smiles.
Um,
the Aau six cheek razor,
the [inaudible] lip corner pole.
And here's the question of can we adapt this to chimps?
So in collaboration with Paul Ekman,
um,
these two researchers developed what they call chimp facts.
Um,
so sort of adapting facts in the human faces.
You can see on the left to the chimpanzee face on the right.
So chimp facts is an objective and standardized system for measuring facial
muscle movement in the face of the chimpanzee and Ben directly comparing it to
humans.
You can see more@chimpfacts.com if you're interested in this.
Um,
so they develop the system in the following ways.
So first they compare the face,
little kind of musculature profiles of chimpanzees and humans.
As you can see roughly here in these drawings.
Next what they tried to do was then sort of identify comparable facial
landmarks.
So what points map on a sort of identically between chimpanzees and humans,
as you can see here.
Then from this,
they arrived at the system of chimp facts.
So Chin facts is really interesting and that it allows for three things.
One you can examine similar facial expression across two very different species
too.
You have a more objective coding system that's really oriented towards,
uh,
facial movements,
um,
muscular contractions as opposed to more,
subjective coding systems that may be subject to kind of these,
anther anthropogenic anthro can never say that word,
uh,
anthropomorphizing animals.
So rather than just subjectively saying that looks like it's happiness and the
chimp,
you can actually more rigorously code that,
um,
by,
by focusing on the muscle contractions.
And this way you can a third,
you can directly compare results between facts and chimp facts.
So
here for example,
we can take CIM facts and facts and compare them across three different kinds of
facial expressions.
So on the top,
what we see here is what's called a silent bared teeth display and chimpanzees,
which is roughly analogous to a human smile.
Um,
in the middle you see these expressions of screaming.
and really if you look here,
you see the associated chimp facts and human facts codes,
um,
and you see striking,
striking a physiological similarities in the face.
Okay.
And then finally,
um,
laughter in humans is roughly analogous to what's called relaxed open mouth or
rom in chimpanzees using the chimp fax system.
So the bottom line here is that expressions are very similar between chimpanzees
and humans,
but they're not actually a hundred percent identical.
You do see some slight subtleties in the different action units on the left with
the chimpanzees to on the right with humans.
So what's interesting here is researchers took this system,
um,
and try to found that the equivalent of smiling and laughter and chimps.
So the SBT and rom there at the top,
right.
Um,
and when they looked at the frequency of when these expressions occurred,
they found that they occurred mainly during positive,
prosocial events or play.
As you can see here,
I'm in the third,
uh,
the third line here to the right.
So you see that occurs highly during play.
So just like humans,
they seem to express experiences of smiling and laughter that seemed to be
matched to these positive and social bonding activities.
Yeah.
Importantly,
um,
we need to always keep in mind that we need to carefully consider the complex,
the context in which these complex emotion expressions occur.
As you can see here,
there's subtle variations and smiling in chimpanzees which can signal joy,
but also there's a fear,
grin or grimace,
which signals something quite different,
which is a sign of submissiveness and distress.
So it's important to when you code the emotional expressions to look at the
context in which it's occurring.
Okay.
And as you can see here,
it's also further complex and so far is that chimp facts reveals at least four
different configurations of these bared teeth displays.
And as you can see here at the bottom from left to right,
they really comprise,
um,
overlapping but distinct patterns of action units or muscle contractions in the
face.
So it's also complex in that they have a lot of varieties and ways in which they
do express these bare teeth displays.
So importantly,
as it says here,
like human smiling,
there may be meaningful variations and bared teeth displays.
So just like human smiles,
chimpanzee smells are also equally complex and rich care.
Considering the context.
And variation smile profiles
and in some,
and sort of what I want you to take home from this is that emotional expressions
do indeed occur in chimpanzees,
but they can only be properly understood when you have a careful objective
coding of the facial expressions that are used using a system such as chimp
facts.
You focus on the underlying emotions signaled by the facial expression.
So you don't just consider the expression in isolation.
And as we just said,
considering the context in which these expressions are being used and what kind
of message they're communicating.
So now we've talked a bit about expression.
Let's turn to emotion recognition.
So we've just talked about how non human primates can express emotions in their
faces,
but now we want to answer the question of whether or not they can also
accurately recognize emotions in other people.
So this maps onto something we talked at the very beginning of class of this
idea of emotional understanding.
So this is the knowledge about whether we or other people are experiencing
emotion.
And one part of emotion understanding is being able to accurately pick up on and
register accused of emotion.
In the faces of others.
So can chimpanzees recognize emotions in others,
not simply express or admit them themselves.
So here's a task that Lisa par and others,
uh,
developed looking at emotion recognition and chimpanzees.
So here what they did is they tried to reliably discriminate between different
facial expressions of emotion using a task,
as you can see here.
So this is also presented in your readings in greater detail,
but let's go through it briefly here.
So in short,
participants were presented with an participants being the chimpanzees this
time.
Um,
they are presented with an initial picture and then a second set of pictures in
which they had to indicate with a joystick which of the two photos match the
original picture.
So they picked two photos with similar feet facial features,
so it to,
so that they could really try to differentiate,
um,
whether or not chimpanzees were able to discriminate different facial features
versus just specific aspects of emotion expression.
So results show that,
um,
chimpanzees we're actually better able to discriminate distinct versus similar
expressions.
Um,
this indicates that they don't just rely on visual features to discriminate
emotional expressions,
that they're actually really able to tease apart one emotion expression from the
other.
Um,
and so what I want to show you now,
this is just a brief clip.
We'll watch it for about a minute and a half.
We've talked about emotion expression,
we've talked about their ability to recognize and discriminated emotions.
So I just want to spend some time now showing you sort of a brief video of what
this work actually looks like.
And here you'll briefly see Dr Lisa par speaking about her work with the
chimpanzees and her approach to developing the system of emotion,
expression and recognition.
I think we can prove that animals have emotions.
I think that there are lots of people now who are starting to learn the
techniques that will enable us to answer those questions.
The study of facial expressions is one way of measuring emotion
chimpanzees have among the most expressive faces in the natural world.
Okay,
thank you Ken.
Believe what you see in a chimpanzee facial expression when they're screaming.
I don't think there's any reason not to believe that they're upset about
something the same way that,
that we would be upset about something.
Studies have already identified at least five universal expressions,
easily recognizable and higher primates,
fear,
disgust,
happiness,
surprise and anger.
Right now we're doing a lot of tests that involve face recognition to get enough
background about emotion and what the chimpanzees understand about their
emotional signals and what they understand about what the,
the context might be if there's been a fight,
if they're involved in calming one another down after a fight when they play,
they have very distinctive facial expressions.
Uh,
and this kind of behavioral evidence gives us the first basis to believe that
these facial expressions have very distinctive meanings and that they do
communicate about different types of emotion,
what the champions,
he understands about their own emotional signals in their own emotional
behavior.
It's really,
I think,
pertinent to understanding a little bit more about the evolution of emotion and
humans and,
and why we are the way we are,
the difference between you and a champion.
Okay.
So that's just a brief excerpt.
If you'd like to see more,
you can watch the discovery channel series,
why dogs smile in chimpanzees cry.
So now I want to turn to the topic of complex emotions.
And here we can,
we're going to try to answer this really perplexing question of do monkeys
experience these more subtle and deep feelings of gratitude or empathy?
Can they have that capacity or is it really reserved solely for the human
species?
So here we'll start by thinking about this question.
Can they experience more complex emotions?
Um,
so these complex emotions,
our thoughts include higher order thinking or cognition that originally was
thought really to be specific to humans with these larger and denser structures.
So these issues are still new and not fully understood.
But I'll present some of the ideas and thinking right now that researchers are
trying to really get their hands on and observationally see whether or not it
appears that they have the capacity monkeys,
like the one you see here to experience things such as empathy or gratitude.
So here we see France to wall who's been studying complex emotions like empathy.
And as you can see here,
he defines empathy as the ability to put yourself in another individual's shoes.
In order to do so though you need what's called a theory of mind or the ability
to mental eyes and sort of,
uh,
get into other's internal emotion states.
So in other words,
can you put yourselves in the shoes of another and really feel their emotions,
see it through their own eyes.
And here he believes that we should see empathy and all species who live in
groups,
not just humans,
because empathy is a really important emotion that is critically necessary for
signaling group alarm as well as really forming and maintaining the mother
infant relationship.
So again,
this is a new area and people are really still coming to terms with how we
measure this and how we get at it.
But what I'd like to show you is a brief clip here that suggest quite
convincingly that it seems that you know,
chimpanzees and other nonhuman primates absolutely have the ability for empathy.
And as you'll see here in this video at suggests that they may have empathy,
not just for their own species,
but also across species and their relationships with human beings.
So let's watch this right now.
What is it that distinguishes humans from all other beings on the earth?
Is the human heart unique or one among many
with her capacity for language,
Washoe was one of the few animals who can share what's in her heart.
I show has expectations of her friends and a few come in four days a week.
Then by Gosh,
she expects even four days a week.
And if you don't come in,
you've got some explaining to do.
I was pregnant in the summer of 1982 and I had a miscarriage and was gone for a
couple days.
So I came in and she kind of gave me the cold shoulder and I said,
I'm sorry I've been gone,
but my baby died and I thought washer would understand because I knew she had
lost a baby before too.
She looked at me and then she looked away and she looked back into my eyes and
she signed cry.
And I knew in that moment that she felt empathy.
I got up to leave and she signed,
she signed please percent talk.
And so I came back and we,
and we visited for a while.
So if you'd like to see more about this again,
you can see this on the discovery channel series by dogs smile and chimpanzees
cry.
Okay.
So what about complex emotions like gratitude?
So gratitude is really defined as this feeling of thankfulness and appreciation.
It's thought to help strengthen social bonding.
And gratitude is experienced when you perceive a favor as costly to the
benefactor or given by the benefactor with benevolent intentions valued by the
recipient and given gratuitously rather than obligatory.
So when we think of complex emotions like gratitude,
again,
we,
we don't have,
uh,
a big host of empirical data at this point.
But again,
we do have these sort of observational,
really telling and very moving,
um,
you know,
experiences shared by people who work closely with nonhuman primates that
suggests that absolutely they experienced feelings of gratitude.
So I'll show you our final clip today.
And while you're watching it think to yourself,
is it possible that nonhuman primates can experience gratitude?
Yeah.
If more proof is needed that animals have the capacity for gratitude.
Washoe is that proof despite a life spent in during the deprivation,
right
captivity
while she and her family live for 13 years in four rooms connected by overhead
tunnels and one a ground level tunnel that connected at very small room at the
end of the hallway on the third floor of the psychology building
wash.
Those providers had wanted to give her and her family a better home,
but it took years to plan,
fund and Build.
Then it's moving day approached.
They wanted to assure the chimps that gaining a new home would not mean losing
old friends
wash.
It had moved twice before in her life and it,
all those moves always involved,
uh,
leaving people behind.
And so I created a video tape of what the new building looked like and
videotaped Roger and Debbie and showed that [inaudible] signed to them.
When I showed it to him and said,
look,
this is your,
your new home,
and showed him some of the different things had followed Roger through and
they're very interested.
When the chimpanzee and Human Communication Institute was finally ready,
the chimps were moved at night.
The next morning wash us family woke in their new home.
They hadn't been out for 13 years.
I mean he hadn't been out in the fresh air and see the sun and can feel the
grass and we thought they would just run out and a
swing and play and so on and we will.
They were excited.
They were hooting and they came rushing out and Moisha rather than going out and
playing.
She came down to a wire area were Debbie and I were standing and she reached to
the wire and she took Debbie space and then went to play.
She was thinking or
five was teared up.
I had tears streaming down my face because it was the true,
she was very,
very grateful.
I uh,
it was,
it was a moment that,
that I think that will forever be indebted in our brains in your memory.
Okay.
And again,
this is also from why dogs smiling,
chimpanzees cry.
So some caveats when we think about trying to understand emotions in nonhuman
primates first,
do you want to be very careful not to anthropomorphize or ascribe human
qualities to what our non human entities or other beings,
we also have unfortunately a lack of confirmatory self report data.
So we haven't yet developed a sophisticated tools to get qualitative self report
measures from,
you know,
chimpanzees for example themselves.
So right now a lot of this is based on observational or behavioral coding.
And then finally we have to always keep in mind that just because they have a
behavioral similarity or they show similar expressive signatures in their face,
it is not equivalent to having the identical or same psychological experience of
that motion.
So with that,
I'll turn to our takeaway questions.
The first question today is which expressions emerge at developmentally similar
time points in both humans and chimpanzees.
Second,
what is the facial coding system for emotion expression and ships?
What is it called and how is it developed?
And then finally,
which higher order or more complex emotions might actually be shared between man
and nonhuman primates.
Well,
now turn to our expert interview,
um,
as part of the experts in emotion interview series and for experts and emotion
interview today.
Um,
we'll be speaking with Dr Lisa Parr who share her expertise on expressions of
emotion and chimpanzees.
Dr Par received her phd in psychology at Emory university and is now an
assistant professor in the division of Psychiatry and behavioral science and
directs a Comparative Research Laboratory at the Yerkes National Primate
Research Center,
uh,
examining emotional communication and social cognition in monkeys and apes.
A doctor par has received several awards in her career,
including the Frank A.
Beach comparative psychology award from the American psychological association
as well as funding from the National Institute of Mental Health,
the National Science Foundation and the National Alliance for autism research.
And on a side note,
as a native Australian,
a doctor par enjoys fishing,
cooking,
and riding her motorcycle.
So we will now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with Doctor
Lisa Par.
Okay,
thanks for another great class.